if this middle game is how to play
against an opponent who is either greedy
and trying to get material and most
certainly he is neglecting his
development and forgetting to Castle
early and the nice thing is that I'm not
showing you examples of claw players or
very low rated players where you might
see in a lot of Scholastic players but
rather players at at the world caliber
strong grandmasters and I was really
amazed that somehow sometimes they just
have an off day because they certainly
know the principles but just sometimes
they choose not to follow them and how
they get punished our first game shows
grandmaster to LaLoosh a very famous
grandmas are playing against former
world champion Mikhail Botvinnik me hell
no Clinic is not exactly the best guy to
do to play footsie against but you know
what ideas like this I said that never
pays off
so d4 Knight f6 c4g 693 d5 so we have a
grim child and I have to tell you
already with the next move I was already
smiling to myself because this is not a
bad line but this is such a tight rope
that you really probably don't wanna
play it again summer-like Botvinnik
and that's Bishop f4 the idea of this
movie is that white further neglects the
development of his key side normal
either you take take off' or does the
main exchange or you play some lines
with Knight f3 III Queen b3 Bishop out
quickly and here this boy basic says I
have time for all of this later let me
develop my Bishop to f4 so the bishop
never stays locked in on c1 okay in
itself not such a bad variation but
against former Doyle played by black you
have to be a little cautious
so Bishop g7 it is very well known that
taking the pawn meaning pawn takes
Knight takes Knight takes Queen takes
Bishop takes c7
might be playable but at the very least
it promises nothing white will always
get his pawn back and again big
development advantage
it's totally playing with fire that was
well known even now so pawn III
castles roof to see one again you notice
that white is declaring something on the
queenside he is saying once again I'm
threatening to take on d5 and then take
on c7 this time with a tempo and the
nice the nice news for for white is that
so far is position is solid there's
nothing much to attack but if things get
open up and they will very soon this
could be very painful so black has to
think of what strategy to play you can
play something like c6 but that's
exactly what white wants he wants to be
passive and cramped then if you complete
this development maintain a very nice
edge space wise or you can play very
aggressively with c5 anybody des plays a
grim field this comes like at the
expected move other people might say
wait a minute doesn't this hang the
world d5 is gonna be less protected c5
with a rock on c1 is going to be hard to
regain and the answer is no look at the
development white is has a king in the
center three pieces on the King side are
you are yet to exit but so far it's
booked it's not tragic or anything
so naturally white takes on c5 that's a
legitimate move I don't have to tell you
that if I get to take once on d4 and
then let's say you play pawn takes and I
get to play knight c6 white is gonna
play with the isolated pawn on d4 and
black has more development and the
bishop almost never belongs on on f4 in
mines like this because when things get
clarified on d5 a knight on d5 is gonna
get a tempo over this Bishop so that's
normal and again the expected response
now the knight on c3 is pinned okay
he played C takes d5 no problem again a
very legitimate move that's one
advantage of having the rook on c1 if
the rook was on a1 if you can imagine
the rook on a1 and the knight on f3 for
example then black could have played
Knight takes d5 right here and now
because I'm Queen takes I could play
Bishop takes c3 and there'll be a rook
in the corner hanging
but the rook is here defending
everything so black plays rook to d8 so
we noticed that not only was black head
in development but after the last two
moves he managed to put his queen on the
ideal square on e5 his rook sleepy rock
on f8 went to d8 and now everything is
ready for action you see black is
definitely the end of open and if white
is smart now is going to start saying
okay let's give something back to the
community so we can continue our life on
tranquil terms because if not it's gonna
hurt White's next move I have to tell
you at first I watch the game by myself
without commentary and without the
computer just so I can get a good idea
of what how well I understood the game
and I think it's a good idea to analyze
game this way as soon as I saw the next
move I thought of myself there is no way
that this move is good and the computer
later agreed and it's like I thought it
was even a kind of a naive plan by white
so he played Queen d2 very very strange
decision I could understand if he if you
play something like let's say d6 and
just pitched upon just try to block the
file because obviously if my threat now
is Knight takes d5 or even rook takes d5
it's just vary with the tempo everything
is going to become very sensitive or
Bishop c4 another logical move develop
the bishop and kind of be a bit stubborn
about the pawn obviously not forever but
do more for the sake of development and
interference than anything else
this move is just a very very naive move
it was based on the tactic but when you
look at the position someone at the
level of a strong Grandmaster definitely
should have appreciated the coming
sequence so of course what the Nick
doesn't in the second invitation for
this obviously and now what to do if you
go knight Knight takes d5 as an example
and I go Queen takes d2 Chuck King takes
d2 rook takes d5 Chuck the white king
this doesn't know what to find a home
what to do with this with this position
it's really I think it's really really
very miserable if you go back to e1
I'm going to go Bishop takes b2
and the white pawn structure looks like
something that got punched by Mike Tyson
you know really terrible structure and
alternatively you can make it even worse
for example again I'm trying to do it
without moving the pieces let me know if
it works for you because I think it's a
good exercise for people at home it's
definitely easy because they can pause
so we are talking now about Knight takes
d5 Queen takes D to check if King takes
must rook takes d5 check King c2 let's
pretend the King goes to defend his c2
upon well that's not gonna work out
because Bishop f5 check King b3 rook d2
and the pawn on b2 is just indefensible
also the pollen f2 doesn't look good and
the white king is not happy at all we're
getting all the material back with
interests with great interest so you
think this up okay
even my little sister could have seen
that the guy's a grandmaster sitting one
with two hours to his clock then I you
know dust was not very complicated what
was he thinking about he was counting on
the following tactic Bishop c7 I was
very proud that I also thought about
this move because I figured there is no
way he is going into something such a
bad ending right off the bat why would
he do that even playing a move like d6
before made more sense than Queen d2 so
he's banking on this continuation of
course the knight cannot take because
the queen is going to take the rock and
this is a fork so you have got to play
this and now this so this is what White
was counting on and you know it's a temp
over the Queen the knight is very well
placed
yeah it's pinned to the Queen but that's
that's that gold both ways if the Queen
goes too far say Queenie five trying to
fork the Queen tonight and the pawn then
Knight f6 check and the Queen is gonna
have a very good taste of this rock so
this is not very good hello so yeah so
what to do where to put the Queen I also
have to really worry about ideas like
Knight xe7 check so I cannot just go
something like Queen c6 or so do I
really have to go
Queen to d7 that wasn't the move that I
really wanted to play as you might
imagine
Queen d7 looks like a really unpleasant
blocking the bishop coming in front of
the rock that spinning the night but in
this position but Vinick assessed
correctly that he is so well ahead in
development and his bishops are going to
be so powerful that time is more
important than the element of material
the element of time is more important
than material we see it in many openings
we see it in many variations
especially in Sicilians especially in
variated where we castle on opposite
sides and here is another good example
of investing just because of what you
get for it so rook takes d5 that's not
an obvious move to me at all that was
very hard to make such a decision
because yeah you can see that the black
pieces are going to swarm out very
quickly they're gonna come to the game
quickly but is it really enough
Kent white the white is also not that
far away from Cass and two three moves
he's there so of course he has to take
and now it's very surprised to learn
later that my move and the move that was
played in the game in the middle I was
thinking about was not the best move at
all the computer really frowns on the
next move and bought the knick played it
and of course everybody wants Bishop e6
tap over the Queen develop the bishop
the Queen has to declare where it wants
to go to when the Queen moves back will
develop the knight will develop the rock
it looks really really quite juicy for
black but it's not the best it's not the
best because we'll see that after Bishop
e6 the Queen is gonna go to d3 and on d3
does a bunch of good things sometimes
wants to go to b5 similar to the game
and also he wants to go to a3 in many
variations a3 is very good it holds on
to the pawn it holds on to the C pawn
and the Queen is awkward but in safety
it's not in danger however the best move
would have been Knight c6 that would
have been a very good move again first
of all putting the the night in the
square where it's coming to before then
Bishop e6 night before combo is going to
be very dangerous and also ideas like
when a5 check are in the offing so okay
but Phoenix plays Bishop e6 and like
I've said
to D 3 would have been the best move
here but he played Queen da Queen d2
kind of transpose into a regular game
and not as good
so 96 black completely managed to solve
the problem of his development and you
can guess that the next move he's
already having his virtual hand on the
rook on a 8 - bring it to d8 with great
great power now what to do again tough
to make a decision in this position he
is really scared of line that involve
rook d8 followed by Queen a 5 check and
there's going to be lots of discomfort
here really really difficult position
there are many behind-the-scenes
variations you could also you know when
you watch the video later on on YouTube
you can also see them I don't want to
spend too much time on them but I'll
mention a few it's enough to say that
both the commentators and the computer
many years later think that the best
move is this move just put a rook in
front of that a very annoying bishop
just tempted take me take me please take
me and of course I will why not it's
five against three I will do that and
also take this thing out of ideas like
Queen a5 check when you have to make a
move like this in this position when you
are dying to develop this side you
already know that something in your
strategy went Blooey definitely so
definitely I mean but this at least
gives you survival chances why because
the material is starting to get reduced
a little bit of course I can play route
d8 but then maybe rook teetering so
maybe I have to first take but okay
after taking and then I'd say that
blocks advantages at a minimum maybe
white can still hold maybe but I much
rather be block here than white I can
take the pollinate - I'm gonna regain it
equality and I'm gonna have to proud
bishops so any ending is gonna be a
little more difficult to play with white
then black however another variation
that will illustrate some of the
problems as Bishop d3 route d8 of course
immediately pinning the bishop already
I'm coming Bishop f5 Knight
95 so the Queen moves Knight e5 hitting
the bishop rule do you want again what
to do with the bishop if you're gonna go
Bishop let's say Bishop c2 or my play
Bishop c4 you know and Queen a5 check is
also looming at some point so very very
difficult so let's see tries to
completely organize things however now
check King f1 I know one thing I know
who I want to be in this position very
easy you don't have to convince me not
to twist my arm here I mean again it
just goes to illustrate how difficult
White's position is just very very
embarrassing so Bishop d3 is also out
rook c3 is the best move he goes rook to
d1 that is for sure the decisive mistake
and again we have played only what just
a dozen or so moves maybe have a little
more and already white a strong
Grandmaster of his time it's just being
throttled like a little mouse in a cat
in a cat's mouth really already is big
just doesn't know what to do so roof d8
again this move comes basically
regardless if any Brook create Quincy
one Quincy to stuff with rook before
it's just gonna be more not a temple
later on
so check rook D - that was the plan he
thought himself well now life is not so
bad yes I'm pinned but there's no more
than normal
rooks to come you cannot do anything to
me you cannot get you cannot use your
dark square Bishop to pin my rock so how
bad can this be sure you can get the a
to pawn back I'll give it to you gladly
just so I can develop my knight develop
my bishop and maybe even play something
like Keaney to and survive it after all
I'm up material I'm up an exchange so
yeah maybe he thought it's gonna be good
until he saw the next move rook d5
fantastic
you cannot temple tunic to take the pawn
on a to this pawn is not going anywhere
there's no rush to rush to
two Russian take it but after Luke d5
now the relentlessness just continues he
realizes that there's not much future in
attacking d2 yeah it's a beautiful pin
but if I cannot add pieces to Meg the
pin piece I have to continue with
something else the root comes to the
fifth rank and he is about to take on c5
and create even more confusion in the
white army what to do now
in the game he went 90 tear here we see
what the threat was the threat was to
take if any let's say h3 or some move
take here take here night before and I
don't know how you stopping night seats
here a very very unpleasant it's just a
complete rush okay so you played 92 here
93 once again white is trying to tempt
the beast with something with some
offerings with some sacrifices
so he will just leave them alone reduce
the material and again black says ok I
have no problem with that let's do that
it looks like this is a great defense
and maybe black will really find it hard
to give such a good dragon bishop for
just a night that was back home two
moves ago and now he's not doing much
but again when the initiative comes why
not
you gotta give stuff to get stuff takes
takes takes already we can see that for
the exchange black got one pawn the
bottom 82 is a gonner at any time and
the Queen is being harassed one more
time so he played Queen B 2 again
probably the most reasonable move and he
played Luke a3 I think the computer said
that was something else even stronger
than that
yeah I think the computer says I was
really laughing when I saw the move
because when I analyze the game if you
ask me oh ok Aviv guess what the
computer suggests here you have five
guesses I'm pretty certain I would not
have gotten that and I'm willing to
challenge I mean maybe not that I said
it maybe somebody will kind of throw the
move
Justin but the movies a six he wants to
play a six with several ideas one the
b-pawn is gonna start moving forward
gaining more space and becoming more and
more annoying but more importantly
stopping the move Queen B 5 because this
maneuver it happened the game forces the
Queen away from its best structure after
a six the computer claims that there's
just no good way no good way for the 4y
to develop even if you play something
like Bishop a 2 then I'm gonna go rook a
3 and again I'm about to take the pawn
on a 2 so you can easily castle and it
just it says decisive ok
in the game we played this immediately
and again the commentators were nice
enough to make those squares green to
illustrate White's problems the bishop
on f1 the rocker h1 miserable pieces so
Queen b5 by far the only move there's
nothing else to even look at here is the
police crossing some is trying is really
dying to trade Queens so Queen C 3
Queen B - with the IDF Quincy 5b Queen a
5 then Queen B 5 again so he went here
and now he plays Queen to be one okay
let's analyze another variation if
Bishop e2 bouquet - Queen B 1 Queen C 3
pinning the rook on D to threaten to win
it you have to go here and of course our
friend the last piece to participate in
the party the knife comes you're not
cancelling and I'm about to go something
like night C - Chuck followed by 93
check and I'm gonna win the world
so again complete misery so we are here
and he played Queen B 1 Bishop takes a -
such an unknowing move to see I have to
tell you very very disappointing he
tries to take it and then of course not
rook takes rook but rather check and now
black has white has two miserable
choices one move is king somewhere and
then of course rook takes a two when
or play this move and here so yeah very
miserable Bishop d3 check here 95 yeah
King you to well the threat was Knight
c4 so here check Bishop here takes takes
now normally a queen against two rooks
is somewhat of a fight but when you add
an A and B pon running down the board
like they're wore sneakers that's not a
fight anymore
so he played here the f5 was another
possibility okay here here a four he
could have pushed immediately and again
the commentator makes all kinds of
suggestions for other moves but at the
end of the day we have an idea those two
moves are just those two pawns just run
here a nice teaser if rook takes a for
Queen c6 check if you take this pawn I
go Quinn c6 check pork in the King in
the pond basically those two pawns
amount to gonna cross the rock
so check here here here and he played
Queen B 525 again the technique part is
not really interesting that's why I'm
going relatively fast at the long run
that the rooks cannot stop such pawns
and in this position black a white
resigned I think maybe it was adjourned
or something in resign yeah I mean it's
gonna be awfully hard to stop something
like b3 rook takes beat you gotta cost
at least Arak and Queen and four pawns
against rook and four pawns well this is
really not something that does botany so
the moral of this game again why it was
very very unambitious in the opening
more greedy than anything else
Queen d2 a very naive move the tactic
Bishop c7 just completely discounted the
possibility of a little investment play
material after which the black piece is
just sprung back guaranteeing the the
return of the investment with great
interest
okay so we are done with this game and
I'm going to show you another game of
the highest caliber former world
champion vasily smyslov
one of the strongest Russian
grandmasters of all time yefim Geller
again this is like as good as it gets
the game was played in 1955 they were
very very strong at a time just very
very I don't think there were ratings at
a time at 1555 but and again you will
see an example of black completely
overpowering white similar to the style
of the game we saw before this time it's
kind of a Kings Indian so King's Indian
you notice that again it's very typical
for Greenfeld and Kings Indian defenses
to warn those kinds of games because
what happens black faces he basically
tells white okay I allow you to build a
very strong center the cost the charge
that I'm charging you is quick
development get my pieces are quickly
castle very early and then the battle is
can I strike at the center and undermine
it or are you gonna maintain that
pressure and get me so okay the same is
variation one of many many possibilities
of a Kingsguard of the King's Indian
councils Bishop III Bishop g5 is another
mainline e5 Knight G to poncey 696
there's another move taking on d4 is
another move d5 takes takes 98 as you
can see the plan as the computer reveals
is to play the move f5 trying to
generate some King side play so far the
game goes more or less in normal for
normal arm Theory lines but now Smith's
top plays a plan that I have to tell you
I was with my eyebrows up for the next
several moves I just didn't understand
it's not it's not exactly recommended
for you he wasn't at the time and I'm
not exactly sure what he was thinking
about honestly I have no clue what he
was aiming for but again this guy was a
world champion you know this is not a
club player so Queen d2 okay this is
still legitimate f5 so first he goes h3
okay why not exactly sure and after
ninety seven he goes g3 a very strange
setup I mean
not only does it cost time but it also
makes the whole kingside pond look a
little funny you know really really
bizarre what's going on here
so Geller was also probably thinking the
same kind of why he thought what can he
do
and he made 96 a very very logical move
I want to go 94 if I'm gonna go night c4
and then at some point take your bishop
when this bishop starts with getting
into life via either Bishop eight-six
it's a moment or Bishop f6 g5 you can
have no counter and without some Bishop
to counter it it's going to be too much
to handle
so b3 not allowing the night to visit c4
and now f4 typical Geller once the long
diagonal was weakened and also the c3
square we can the meaning when I'm gonna
use the C file it is not going to be a
pawn on b3 to just close it straight up
then this is warranty and sacrifice it's
not it it's not even a sacrifice right
now as you will notice but even if it
was a sacrifice there's just no nothing
to really be amazed by because
everything just opens up so you took it
took it and he went Bishop to d4 now
obviously you cannot take on f4 for
several reasons like if you take on f4
I'm always gonna take on c3 again it's
very counterintuitive but when you win a
piece it's worth it so let's say Bishop
takes F for Bishop takes c3 something
takes on c3 Queen h4 check for king the
queen and whatever poor soul is here and
I'm just gonna take it so that's gonna
win material so he went Bishop d4 okay
now what again it's time to think of an
idea and all right so the idea was to
open up the bishop and he immediately
closed the diagonal how can I enjoy my
new square when I look at this square
like a5 and you should also immediately
think to yourself man that's a beautiful
square there's no deep on that can never
kick me out the f1 is blocked by my own
f1 so you can kick me out this way
this mean this is practically a lifetime
a lifelong outpost so what piece do I
want to have here if you said rook I'm
gonna cry
so I'm hoping it's not a rock so 97
denied finish this job on b6 I'm not
gonna go to c4 I'm not gonna go to a4
let's bring it back to civilization
straight to the e5 square h4 I think
that sooner already you can do it I mean
you could have changed the move order
and play something like Bishop g2 kind
of crying before you hurt but then 95
so just transposing and then maybe
castlelong but again I think that sooner
or later to generate some play you'll
have to push the H pawn I don't know if
it really made a difference between
pushing it now or doing casting first so
he pushed it 95 with a big threat on f3
so Bishop g2 not exactly his dream
square for the bishop but what we when
we must we must Bishop d7 the last
undeveloped piece comes to the game and
now rook c8 is ready to ready to operate
I have to say that in this position the
computer was saying to also play Knight
f6 the IDF Knight f6 is never to allow
h5 maybe to play Knight h5 yourself to
take control of some squares but I was
thinking myself 9 f6 what if I just take
on e5 killing the good night along with
giving myself a protected passport that
in itself is not really something that's
moving soon but then I'm also killing
the diagonal of the bishop but the
computer claims it's okay as a human I
can bring myself to make this move
really sorry it just to me it's like I
love my bishop I love my knight there's
I'm in no rush to grow Knight f6 I'm not
really afraid of h5 because it cannot
play d5 and then g4 becomes a serious
move on the agenda so but computer said
you know when the computer says the
computer knows
and then the bishop will change
diagonals are you know what I agree i I
can disagree I think that already white
strategy of playing h3 g3 and putting a
bishop on g2 it's that's not what that's
not a doctor or not what the doctor
orders miss la whatnots miss love sorry
so but okay this is of course also an
acceptable plan and he played Bishop f2
yeah
this was again not the most recommended
move Bishop F Jim I think that the
computer suggested something like
casting long putting the King in safety
somehow but again black is just better I
don't have to tell you that night x f4
is going to be answered but rook takes
f4 Queen takes F 493 check so the point
of f4 is just for decoration it's not
for using so he played bishop f2 rook c8
an easy move to make lots of control on
the diagonal and he played 94 again it's
very understandable that he wants to
block that Bishop on g7 he must have
something stay on d4 probably the bishop
would have been the best I don't think
that the knight move is really helping
because as you will notice block just
gets more and more free moves the
initiative just swarms
so anyways 94 Queen a5 again sometimes
by process of elimination you can tell I
mean the knight is as good as it gets
the bishop can't improve his position I
can play Knight f6 but I'm in no rush
you have to think that at some point
maybe white wants to play 96 2
completely discombobulated the black
position if you could somehow
miraculously movies wrote throw 96 and
after the capture grow 95 after the pawn
moves here maybe he is gonna generate
some counter play of his own so black is
giving him no rest Queen a5 immediately
on the knight on c3 rook c1 and
understandable move and black plays
again let's think of what he should play
again process of elimination my rook is
again as good as it gets I can't really
improve this bishop same to be said
about those pieces
so this night right basically you can
tell the night on e 8 is my least
favorite piece so I have to choose a
direction for it should I go this way or
in the game look what he did just
marvelous when you think that this night
in 2 seconds is going to play a really
important part of the game you think wow
really is the time for it answer is yes
97 already you can see the arrows of the
suggestion of the rod
there's even an improvement in a second
you will see because again it just
exists
so he played rook sea to the computers
first choice Knight a six castles on
move 22 finally he managed to castle but
if he thought if he's gonna get relief
the answer is no so what would you play
here again I was really surprised that
first of all I didn't see the move
myself but I have to tell you that this
part I was so disillusioned about white
setup with the bishop on f2 bits of g2
cancelling into this funny setup it's
obvious to me that black is just very
happy so I wasn't really I was really
trying to guess moves but I was
surprised to see that the computer
suggested that in the game he went
Knight c5 okay who can complain right
that's just a fantastic move but it's
funny that the computer suggests my D 3
just a beautiful little tactic it's like
really in your face kind of move 93 of
course I want to eliminate the bishop as
one thing I also threatened to play
Knight before and where is this route
going and of course if you wanted to
know what happened if I take the knight
that looks like a freebie
I'm gonna go night before forking the
Queen and the rook
when the Queen moves and it has to move
I'll take the rook and then this knight
on c3 is also hanging everybody
understands should I should I make the
move so you understand you understand
right 93 if you don't take my knife is
just going to create havoc and the other
one is coming to before and if you take
I go night before fork the Queen in the
rock take it take it and Knight c3 so 93
very very strong but he played here also
who can complain about this
really excellent now what to do is white
again it's I wouldn't say it's a Zuke's
line position but it's really hard to
recommend the move normally you would
want to play a natural move like rook to
c1 and fight for the file but I'm
immediately putting a knight on d3
attacking everything and at the minimum
taking the measure that's totally not
helping so he tries to reduce the
material by offering a queen trade and
growing not see - you know again
expecting the Queen to go back somewhere
but black says you want to treat Queens
I'm ready for it I'm totally in for it
why because after the Queen trade I have
a very simple tactic that guarantees me
and ending with a very active rook -
strong bishops let's take a look takes
takes BAM
Knight takes e4 you have to take f3
immediately regaining my invested
material now I'm all over the pieces now
really this is becoming not so funny
right I'm really attacking everything so
he tries to take take forking everything
takes in takes the storm is over I now
have two bishops I the white pawns are
extremely weak and in case you didn't
notice I also got my material back in
the process so life is really really not
that fun for white very hard to defend
if you put it in the computer the
computer is going to say yeah maybe
black is like up one point but I can
still defend it in other words you have
to be super accurate for twenty-some
moves to not lose it but for a human
especially someone at the level of
Smith's table realizing how yucky is
position is it's very hard to defend a
position like this
so Bishop takes a seven that's
reasonable route case three yeah
everything is going to come back Bishop
F to Bishop e5 okay again a very good
move but the computer claims that Bishop
eight six was pretty much winning
immediately Bishop eight six row goes to
B - where else Bishop g4 miserable
position like really really bad
like two missions with two rooks all
active all around I can always get my
pawn back I mean those pawns are just
falling like flies so but okay this is
not exactly spoiling anything Bishop e5
Knight d4 okay Bishop g4 again look at
the activity
I'm practically basically guaranteeing
that you cannot move well anything if
you move the night I go Bishop f3 and
you're gonna get mated if you move this
Bishop where are you going to move this
Bishop here I take it here I take it
so Bishop II 1 practically the only move
to to make here and he did rookie 3 now
that the bishop moved I'm starting to
pick on the pawns Bishop back rook takes
e4 rook e1 takes takes rook c1 and that
was all she wrote because now he is just
losing I think he resigned here yeah
simply because well what are you going
to play if you play the move King f1 for
example I'm going to go here
Knight c2 I guess the defender Bishop
and then I'm just going to take this guy
now make him move good luck you know
it's like the rook is defending the
night the night is defending the bishop
the bishop is pinned the King isn't
really going too far because he has to
defend defend the bishop and I have
those two marchers I'm gonna go h5
bishop g3 H 4 H 3 and have a really good
time alternatively after this maybe King
F 2 is another move and not a try
but after you know him
after this move White has really lost
the eagerness of continuing very very
displacing a beautiful show by Miguel ER
really very aggressive game I mean
that's the kind of game if I played it I
would go home really feeling like I get
all my aggressions out for the day or
for the week okay so we are done with
this one and I suppose we do have time
yeah sure why not
now we'll see another
masterpiece this time Paul carrots who
was they just celebrated I think a
hundred years to his Bertha assuming
birth in Estonia he was really one of
the best players in the world i one of
my friends wrote some article recently
and he called him the eternal number two
player because I think five times he
missed a chance to qualify for the
finals of the of the World Championship
his opponent is Mark Hyman off again a
strong Russian Grandmaster a former
candidate very famous for losing to
Fischer 6-0 in their round of eight I
think
match in the 70s before he played
eventually Spassky for the title so
watch this game d4 Knight of six c4 e6
93 bishop before this line was very very
very much in fashion at the time it was
even more in fashion some years later
when Kasparov used to play it maybe
something like 30 years later
Knight of 3 b6 Bishop g5 is kind of a
combination that Queen's Indian
nimzo-indian type of structure and again
a variation where white is gaining a lot
of space getting the center but black is
getting very quick development so III h6
Bishop h4 g5 all this is very well known
here 94 I am thinking if I'm not
completely crazy that Knight d2 is one
of the main moves here even though it
gives up a pawn here it's kind of again
nothing to be afraid of to give such a
pawn but of course Queen c2 is also a
normal line Bishop takes c3 I think f5
also is a possibility or d6 and f5 so
takes but again it's not the opening
we're discussing so much as the middle
game so pawn takes pawn to d6
controlling the e5 square here f5 ok so
we have reached the position from which
I wanted to start and again in this
position you have to think yourself well
what to do the deal
was made I have two bishops if I'm white
but they have a very annoying weakness
have double pawns and a very poor
structure broken structure from black
I'm happy about the structure I'm really
missing a dark square bishop if somehow
I could bring a dodge to a bishop into
the game I'll be really happy like if I
could trade my knight here that does
nothing for him
so she's me if you're white you have to
think yourself okay how do I activate my
pieces right now my knight is not going
forward anywhere my bishop is not going
forward anywhere this bishop is being
stopped by a knight so it's like black
is having a lot of control in the in the
center right now and how do I get
activity one move that you might
consider is to play a move like 92 but
after 90 XD - I might be able to take
this pawn so you might be thinking okay
let's castle first then of course I have
I'm just in time to play like 97 9 f6
and complete my development so it offers
some thinking caris who is never someone
to shy away from a real battle comes up
with d5 very very good this motif
happens a lot in this variation really a
lot and you really have to know what to
do
in a position like this and here I think
it was a little bit naive of time enough
to play but maybe you have to remember
again that this game was played in 1955
the evolution of this variation is
basically in his in his diapers this is
just the start of really discussing this
line not really
we're talking about 30 years later where
everything was well known and played
automatically 30 minutes so what he does
I think is not the best so he takes it
alternatively I'm trying to remember
what was the alternative there was some
idea where you just give up this pawn
but I don't remember how it goes
maybe Queen f6 first something like this
yeah maybe Queen f6 would have been a
much better move here yeah but he goes
for it because again at first glance you
gave me a pawn and why should I not take
it what's wrong with it
so the pond was sacrifice the idea was
again to create lots of counter play
lots of open lines and watch what
happens okay step 194 no rush to castle
you could Castle also the small a big
deal but first of all I'm already thanks
to the removal of the pawn on e6 the
pawn on f5 becomes really really weak
not only is it weak but it's also
supporting the knight on e4 so if I get
it
if I take this pawn if I suck even for
this pawn and then I regained it by
taking on e4 I'm gonna win my piece back
in an instantly and I've gained upon my
sacrifice pawn what's more thanks to
this structure of h6 and g5 the black
King side is irreversibly weakened and
it's gonna take awful long time to try
to castle this way so in this position
already Weis compensation completely
overtakes the upon so he plays 97 and
white kind of transposed Queen f6 also
would have led to f3 and after Knight
take g3 HDX g3 and again the pawn on f5
has no good way of being defended
so 97 you could excuse me
kill it so of course you can take the
pawn on f5 immediately there's nothing
wrong with it but f3 knowing that the
pawn on f5 is not going anywhere
Knight takes g3 one tank g3
again you can see that white is
completely ready black really wishes
that there was a game where he could put
his pawns backwards if you could play
ff7 and then g7 yeah he'll be alright
so Queen f6 Bishop takes f5 castles all
right
this was blacks only planned we can
agree right there was nothing else but
try to bring the King to safety no way I
can leave it in the center and there's
no way I'm casting the other way with
this rook and the H fall and probably a
chance to double and again White has
many possibilities here
for example a4 is one mention move but
he plays Queen a4 very very nice it's
beautiful when you play a move like this
not only are you tickling the pollen a7
and boy will I take it if you give it to
me but he says forget about King b7
forget about team b8 because this guy
needs some extra help
he's attacked twice you cannot move it
so it's either lose it or make another
weakness in the position which he is
forced to make ok now again a lot of
ways to gain Tempe but he plays very
very quietly he could play E for c4 all
those moves
but King f2 not only putting the king in
safety but the other rook is coming into
the game as well
h5 what else to generate some counter
play if not aged 5 and H for ok again
efore was recommended by one of the
commentators again a very good move but
he played rook to be 1 h4 and again in
this position I can either take on h4 I
can play g4 or I can play what was
played in the game which was if ofö was
played sorry I'm in gh4 o g4 you Andy
for was played all of them are equally
good here if you take on g3 King takes
g3 you might say well the king is on g3
but the computer is not impressed and
neither was Harris
so Bishop e7 again g4 is another move to
consider takes takes and 96 okay
now the best move would have been to
play queen takes c3 after which Queen d1
is the recommended move and rook c1 is
already coming with no checks or
surprises and white is really really
hurting and of course the threat now is
Knight takes c7 as you will see so he
did 95 but that was that was definitely
a question mark well the black position
is just very difficult very hard
I mean if rook e8 then of course Knight
takes c7 notice that the knight on D 7
it's just not very well protected
so black position is just an enviable so
it breeds mistakes that we said here of
course he could have played Knight takes
da check King takes d8 Queen d4 but no
rush Queen D for immediate thing very
very difficult position already you can
see that there's a very poor chain of
ponds and now I'm interested in playing
check King takes Queen takes b6 check
and Quint xb7 mate so he went rogue here
Knight xe7 there was really no way to do
anything in this position position is
just just miserable
so here takes King b8 Queen takes be 693
check ok King F 1 this is just in lieu
of resigning and at first I thought that
night c5 saves the day maybe that was
his idea
I'm guessing maybe he thought it after
95 he gets lots of counter play but
mary-6 check just wins because you
cannot take with the night because it's
mate and otherwise if you move the King
I'm just going to take on c5 and
everything is saying you can't even take
back as it's made and I'm not to mention
the Queen so night before
and again maybe some tricks maybe
there's a chance to play something like
Queen takes III know maybe if the Queen
moves Bishop a6 Jack but he just does
takes takes 95 you know things are bad
when the computer suggests Queen takes
f5 in this position then it's a it's a
pretty good sign
pretty pretty good sign that things are
not not going well of course Queen a7
check made very hard to stop
so resigns again in all three games I
hope that you have seen that the common
theme in an opening when one sides allow
the opponent to build a strong center
and or yet get some little amount of
material the compensation comes in in in
form of quick development very strong
activity and of course often times as
you will see it requires further
investments either of an exchange or a
piece or a pawn almost always it's a
good idea because you get very quick
piece play when you play it when you
play this I always recommend it because
again maybe now the main measuring the
measuring stick is playing against
stockfish basically or komodo or one of
those computers and they will take the
material and sometimes they'll be able
to defend sometimes later on into the
variation they admit to that there's a
lot of compensation and that it's very
difficult and if they can make a draw
that'll be an achievement but remember
when you play humans that's almost
always the recommended way to go I tell
my students always play those gambits
play those aggressive openings we have a
chance to sacrifice even if the
sacrifice is saying equal or that
doesn't mean a draw
just yesterday at a lesson with one of
my students that I'm showing our
variation and in the variation she tells
me yeah but the computer says that even
after this sacrifice and even after this
sacrifice if black plays accurately it
says that it's like only 0.1 for white
and it says equal I told her yeah it's
eco but it's not a draw and go figure
you think that you're 2,000 a point is
really gonna find it or an 1800 he's
really gonna find all those defenses and
even if he does it's still a game and he
still has further hurdles and if worse
comes to worse
okay so he made a draw congratulations
jess is not like to move and win so
anyways that was the lecture hope you
enjoyed it and I'll be here again next
week